[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle émission de points de
vue avec quatre sujets qu'on va traiter
aujourd'hui et que je vous propose de
découvrir sans plus tarder nous allons
parler du mouvement des gilet jaune qui
continue même s'il a un moindre succès
mais qui se radicalise aussi avec de
vrais dérapages les gilets jaunes sont
ils devenus trop violent on se posera la
question
on s'interrogera aussi sur la sphère
carlos ghosn le patron de renault nissan
qui est toujours en garde à vue pour
fraude fiscale au japon
c'est quand même l'homme carlos ghosn
qui a sauvé l'industrie automobile
japonaise alors les japonais sont ils
des ingrats vous nous donnerez votre
point de vue nous parlerons aussi des
syndicats alors que force ouvrière se
cherche un nouveau patron pour succéder
à pascal pavageau risque atteint général
qui mettait tout le monde en fiche les
mêmes syndicats sont totalement à la
ramasse sur le mouvement des gilet jaune
en at-on encore besoin faut-il les
sauver on se posera la question et puis
on s'interrogera on s'intéressera plutôt
aux européennes
du côté des républicains qui se cherche
toujours une tête de liste ils ont quand
même une idée en tête un jeune
professeur de philosophie c'est
peut-être une idée baroque
on verra on en parlera avec nos quatre
invités bonsoir lucile schmid
vous êtes co président de la fondation
verte européenne on rappelle que votre
dernier livre la france résiste-t-elle à
l'écologie a été publié aux éditions du
bord de l'eau
christophe de voogd bonsoir vous êtes
historien professeur à sciences po vous
enseigner la rhétorique et des idées
politiques
parmi vos ouvrages récents la
participation à celui ci où va la
démocratie ça a été publié chez plon les
dernières et c'est un ouvrage en
collaboration christian makarios et là
aussi bon soir christian directeur
délégué de la rédaction de l'express
l'express qui nous régale cette semaine
d'une couverture forte sur les
agressions contre les homosexuels
un homo agressé toutes les 33 heures
assez et puis philippe meyer est là
aussi bons soient ravis de vous
accueillir dans cette émission vous
d'être journaliste écrivain animateur
d'une nouvelle esprit public qu'on
retrouve chaque dimanche en podcast et
puis votre dernier livre les gens de mon
pays a été plus
et chez robert laffont on commence donc
par parler c'est pas très nouveau mais
ça évolue tous les jours des gilet jaune
le mouvement traîne en longueur avec des
événements un peu surprenant des
familles entières ont ainsi passé la
nuit dans leur voiture sur l'autoroute
a10 était en gironde il ya de vrais
phénomènes de violence c'est
particulièrement aiguë à la réunion où
il ya quasiment eu carrément eu un
couvre-feu est ce que les jets les
jeunes sont trop violents c'est en tout
cas l'avis de benjamin griveaux le porte
parole du gouvernement qui en a parlé ce
matin à la sortie du conseil des
ministres et qui s'est efforcée on peut
le dire de discréditer le mouvement
il faut être intraitable sur l'ordre
public la liberté n'existe que si il y à
l'ordre public
il ne pouvons accepter les deux
personnes qui sont décédées les
centaines de blessés chez les
manifestants
et bien sûr les blessés chez les forces
de l'ordre ne pouvons pas non plus
accepter les propos racistes xénophobes
antisémites homophobes qui parfois ont
été entendues ont été filmées ont été
tenus à l'endroit de certains de nos
compatriotes qui se trouvaient là la
réponse de l'état a été ferme et la
sévérité sera de mise comme elle l'a été
depuis le premier jour christophe de
voogd discours sur le malaise des
français que l'on entend apparemment est
terminé maintenant c'est plutôt le bâton
ça vous paraît une bonne une bonne
réponse
j'observe c'est ce que la communication
appelle le cadrage est ce qu'on appelle
en rhétorique tous plus classiquement la
substitution
on passe d'un registre à un autre et là
on est passé en effet à l'argument on va
dire à deux types d'arguments à
l'argument ad hominem c'est à dire qu'on
attaque les gilet jaune et en maths et
on utilise les arguments d'influents
c'est à dire la peur la peur du désordre
la peur de l'anarchie et le l'argument
d'autorité nous sommes l'état nous
devons faire et donc qu'ils sont vos
arguments tout à fait respectable le
grand problème que j'ai moi avec toute
cette affaire depuis le début a su
redonner vie
raison aucun des camps c'est que
l'absence d'argumentation sur le fond
c'est à dire et je parle sous contrôle
l'argumentation écologique il suffit pas
de dire c'est pour la transition
énergétique c'est pour la transition
énergétique
là le dossier du gagnant est quand même
beaucoup plus faible je moi je signale
une chose qu on entend très peu quand
même dans les médias on a voté la cape
taxe carbone en 2015
depuis 2015 la france augmente ses
émissions à effet de serre elle les
augmente
je rappelle que dans le même temps les
états unis l'europe et les ori des
américains les diminue une chose qu'on
ne dit jamais bon la deuxième chose
c'est que quand un gouvernement dit nous
allons augmenter la taxe carbone il nous
allons récolter 3 milliards et demi
d'euros
avec cette augmentation par définition
il n'attend pas à ce que se produise une
substitution que ce qu'il attend des
recettes fiscales supplémentaires
je crois que c'est une contradiction du
raisonnement qui échappent beaucoup et
qui moi me paraît un peu gênante du
point de vue de l'argumentation de fond
donc bref ce serait pas mal de revenir à
l'argumentation de fond parce que ce que
disent certains certes un gilet jaune
vise justement cette argumentation de
fonds le cilss mais il est devenu trop
violent ce mouvement je parle de la
réunion on peut remarquer quand même que
même s'il ya eu plusieurs dizaines de
blessés notamment chez les forces de
l'ordre eh bien les manifestants ont
obtenu satisfaction c'est à dire le gel
de cette taxe carbone à la réunion
jusqu'à 2021
peut-être que la violence est aussi un
moyen de se faire entendre
je pense que non bien sûr je suis en
faveur comme je pense l'ensemble des
personnes sur ce plateau de la non
violence
ce que je voulais dire par rapport à
ascain dire christophe c'est que il ya
une absence d'anticipation de la part du
gouvernement parce que cette
manifestation a été lancée sur les
réseaux sociaux et que quand on organise
les manifestations sur les réseaux
sociaux on néglige la question du droit
et la question de l'organisation concret
d'une manifestation une manifestation ça
se déclare en préfecture il faut trois
organisateurs et lorsqu'elle n'est pas
déclaré c'est un attroupement le sujet
là c'est qu'il ya eu je crois quelques
dizaines de manifestations légalement
déclarés et la très grande majorité
étaient en fait des attroupements
après il ya eu un choix du gouvernement
de ne pas reprendre et les choses en
amont sans doute parce qu'il sentait
qu'il avait une certaine légitimité en
termes de pouvoir d'achat
deux sets de l'objet du contenu même de
cette manifestation
en revanche sur la question de la
fiscalité écologique on voit bien que la
difficulté c'est qu'il ya plusieurs
sujets qui s'emboîtent les uns dans les
autres cas le sujet de l'ordre public
mais qui surgit une fois que l'ordre
public a été bafoué moi je trouve que le
gouvernement là dessus il a des torts il
aurait dû cadrer les choses et je trouve
aussi que les différents menus quoi
interdire les rassemblements a forcément
l'interdire mais je trouve
il aurait dû rappeler puisque ça fait 15
jours qu'on nous racontait qu'elle avoir
une manifestation du gilet jaune il
aurait dû en amont rappeler que
manifestation ça s'organise qu'il faut
déclarer les choses en préfecture et
sera dû être fait aussi sur les
territoires donc il y avait une question
de maillage du territoire en prévention
en anticipation
la deuxième chose c'est que les
différents leaders politiques qui ont
soutenu sans la soutenir tout en la
soutenant cette manifestation on
négligeait le aussi cette question du
droit et je trouve que sur le plan des
contre-pouvoirs des opposants à emmanuel
macron il ya eu aussi une forme de moi
je trouve d'irresponsabilité c'est à
dire que tout le monde était en train de
se dire est ce que je peux récupérer les
gilet jaune contre emmanuel macron et on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui étant donné
qu'il ya deux morts plusieurs centaines
de blessés
tout le monde est gêné mais quand on
voit la façon dont ça s'est passé le
jour j je pense qu'il ya eu aussi des
responsabilités de l'ensemble de la
classe politique
opposante à emmanuel macron lors 6 août
à il ya eu évidemment marine le pen ça
on s'y attendait mais jean-luc mélenchon
je trouve a fait preuve d'une absence de
discernement assez forte et laurent
wauquiez aussi mais sur le fond sur le
fond l'argumentation sur le fond sur la
fiscalité écologique
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion d'ailleurs d'en
débattre avec avec philippe moi je
rappelais que get bouchardeau en 1983 a
commandé un rapport qui montrait que le
diesel était cancérigène
donc il ya un sujet sur le fait que le
tête-à-queue en fait de la politique
menée par les pouvoirs publics
interroge les français qui disent mais
pourquoi on nous a menti depuis trente
ans et ça c'est un sujet essentiel
et la deuxième chose qui dise et on va
encore nous pomper notre argent et ce ne
sera même pas affecté à la transition
écologique
c'est un deuxième argument assez fort et
de bon sens on vous pose la question sur
twitter trouvez vous que les mouvements
des gilets jaunes soit devenu trop
violent vous ne répondez non à 57 % donc
c'est assez équilibré sur le figaro.fr
lila nous dit je ne crois pas une
seconde que les violences soient le fait
des gilet jaune monsieur babineau qui
est aussi sur ce même
registre la grande majorité des gilet
jaune reste pacifiste c'est
irresponsable de caricaturer ce
mouvement philippe meyer est ce que
selon vous il ya des dérapages limitée
ou c'est le mouvement lui-même qui est
remis en question dans ça dans sa
légitimité elle trois choses comme le
disait le porte parole du gouvernement
nous ne pouvons pas accepter que soit
tenu des propos racistes des propos
xénophobes les propos homophobes et
toutes sortes de propofol qu'on a pu
entendre ici et là nous ne pouvons pas
non plus accepter qu'on parle de gilet
jaune comme de la france qui fument des
clopes qui roulent au diesel
c'est justement le porte parole du
gouvernement qui a eu cette expression
malheureuse m sila dire l'irec
finalement il leur a dit il a démenti
mollement salive un bref le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que quand on dit qu'on
n'a pas dit on ne fait qu'aggraver ce
qu'on a dit parce que évidemment on a
été enregistré on l'a dit devant témoin
ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire des gilets jaunes on peut dire
qu'ils sont jaunes sortis de là on a
beaucoup de mal parce qu'il ya une telle
diversité de manifestants que oui
incontestablement il y à des endroits où
des gilets jaunes se sont comportés de
manière violente
il ya d'autres endroits ce péage
d'autoroute notamment où des casseurs
sont venues des gilets jaunes ont essayé
de s'opposer à eux et n'ont pas réussi
parce que les casseurs avaient des
barres dont ils se sont servis entre
autres pour taper sur des gilets jaunes
puis une troisième chose qui peut
paraître marginal mais à laquelle je
tiens il ya en ce moment le congrès des
maires de france qui se drapent dans une
vertu admirable et dans le fait qu'ils
sont paraît-il les seuls élus qui est
vraiment la confiance des français
mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait les
maires de france pour empêcher cette
france que gulli a appelé périphériques
de devenir de plus en plus périphériques
avec l intensité se sont ils mobilisés
pour empêcher les fermetures de voies
ferrées pour empêcher un certain nombre
de décisions qui ont fait que encore
ceux qui sont dans cette france
périphérique se sont sentis de plus en
plus périphériques
je ne vois rien qui ressemble de leur
part à une véritable prise de conscience
en dehors pardon christophe de la
rhétorique car tout ça toutes nos
mauvais sens du terme et qu'ils aient
contribué à faire en sorte que un
mouvement comme celui là ne soit pas
justifiée mais qu on entre à niveau
lorsque vous dites que c'est un
mouvement qui reste légitime même si les
dérapages sont condamnés avec comment
est-ce qu'on peut délégitimer un
mouvement de gens qui ont le sentiment
qu'il n'y a aucune espèce de relais à
des considérations qu'il considère que
beaucoup d'analystes considèrent comme
légitime
après les formes que prend ce mouvement
les erreurs qui ont été faites dans leur
organisation ou même son absence
d'organisation sont en effet des choses
qui peuvent avoir des conséquences
fâcheuses
mais l'idée de les regarder de haut en
disant écoutez rentrez chez vous parce
que ça va pas du tout tout ce que vous
faites ne nous convient pas et reprenez
votre diesel est rentré à la maison je
veux clame s'il vous plaît encore le
plus poli des membres du gouvernement
qui dit s'il vous plaît j'ajoute pour
compléter ce que vous disiez sur les
casseurs que à la réunion l'essentiel
des violences est d'ailleurs le fait des
casseurs qui se sont des jeunes casseurs
qui se sont substitués au gilet jaune
même pour des affrontements extrêmement
violents en particulier avec la police
christian makarian ce qu'il faut qu'ils
rentrent chez eux c'est gilet jaune
non non
leur colère est légitime tout autant
qu'eux
elle respecte les règles de droit mais
je voudrais dire trois choses pas pour
pas un principe qui également avec trois
inflation moi que c'est pas une règle de
la rhétorique et de l'institut d'etudes
politiques qui les gars de la parole
longtemps dans des bars qui préfèrent
laboratoire partie du reste
mais ces universités qui aiment le plein
de trois partielles et un sens même
sciences po la salle mais mais revenons
à notre débat
christian matin à troyes je vous avoue
dire qu'ils vont être bref pour que le
national forcément le plus compétent que
les cours se voulait préalablement
premièrement philosophique mais que tout
cela était prévisible qu'on ne comprenne
pas que des êtres humains dans une
société organisée et dans une vieille
république sociale fatigué comme l'est
la france n'accepte pas la sensation de
perte de diminution de réductions et
quelque chose
à commencer par ceux qui ont moins est
quelque chose d'assez évident me parait
t'il une deuxième réflexion qui est
d'ordre historique
quand est ce que les hommes politiques
français apprendront à faire autre chose
qu'un vantait des impôts directs ou
indirects autrement appelée taxe
depuis l'ancien régime
il en est ainsi et on sait très bien que
ça provoque toujours des colères je n'ai
jamais vu de ma vie un système qui
consiste un système politique qui
consiste au jet à dire aux gens on va
polluer moins
ça va être formidable vous aller
respirer de l'air pur
et pour ça il va falloir payer des
impôts je vois pas le rapport
troisièmement une réflexion d'ordre
politique
il était évident que les gilet jaune
allait ressembler à ça et que ce
mouvement à lui échappé à toutes les
structures habituelles de qui représente
la société puisqu'elles sont toutes
fatiguées
on a parlé de la politique et du dga gym
il ya un dégagisme syndical on va en
parler tout à l'heure et un dégagisme
comme laborde et philippe par rapport
aux élus locaux qui se prétendent
effectivement et plus légitime et plus
proche du peuple
il n'y a plus rien qui soit proche du
peuple le peuple est orphelin
en tout cas ces gens-là leçons alors
qu'ils soient vulgaire qui fument des
clopes qui est des invectives les
automobilistes qu'il traite quelqu'un
d'efféminé de ceci ou de cela je le
crois volontiers et je le condamne mais
c'était hélas prévisible et encore une
fois la faute et à ceux qui ont engendré
ce mouvement et pas uniquement à ceux
qui les propagent
je suis là n'est moins sûr c'est un tout
petit mot c'est juste pour dire qu'il
faut quand même pas qu'on passe sous
silence la question de la violence je
voudrais rappeler qu aux émeutes de 2005
non mais oui mais on excuse je trouve
trop enfin ce qui me concerne parce que
pendant les émeutes de 2005 qui avait
zéro mort les émeutes des banlieues des
banlieues difficiles lorsqu'on à évacuer
notre dame des landes ya eu zéro mort et
là il ya deux morts et des centaines de
blessés
donc ce sujet ne sont pas de fait les
manifestants quand même nom mais bien
sûr mais ça veut dire que les médias
vont réaliser ses marques et un gilet
jaune une femme que tout après on aurait
aimé on réalise en fait que la voiture
la moto en fait tous les engins de
transport sont dangereux et c'est
quelque chose qui vise mais on n'avait
pas du tout été anticipée serre que
quand on est voiture contre piéton
ça produit des morts et là il ya ça
c'est non seulement la nouveauté cette
manifestation par rapport à la question
des réseaux sociaux aussi c'est que
brusquement on s'aperçoit que la voiture
tue et ça c'est un truc qui me semble
important mais il ya eu quand même des
déferlements de violence moi j'ai
regardé les vidéos il ya des gens qui
étaient secoués dans leur voiture il ya
eu quand même beaucoup d' insultes dont
il ya une forme de violence qui était
aussi verbale et ya des jambes rejet je
connais des personnes qui ont été
confrontées qui ont peur donc ne
négligeons pas le fait que la violence
monte et face à cette violence qui peut
être qu est ce que vous suggérez la
répression face à l'abc mans pas je
suggère je suggère juste une chose c'est
qu'on organise les choses que des
contre-pouvoirs et jeudi que le
spontanéisme des manifestations ne
résout pas la question démocratique et
n'apportent pas davantage d'ailleurs de
réponse
je trouve aussi que la réponse du
gouvernement en disant vous pourrez vous
acheter une nouvelle voiture et une
réponse extrêmement faible et que et
j'observe que la demande a été largement
une demande de service
quand euros par mois on vous propose
d'en dépenser 15 milles pour acheter une
nouvelle voiture si je la trouve
extrêmement faible mais presque insuline
va pas revenir sur le fond du traitement
du dossier
aujourd'hui on se focalise vraiment sur
la violence en tout cas nous internautes
aussi ont des ondes et des propositions
des suggestions pour répondre à
l'interpellation de christian makarian
nicole nous dit il faudrait que les
gilet jaune exfiltre sans violence ceux
qui viennent mettre le bazar c'est aussi
l'avis d'un imac et celui de lille à qui
nous dit il faudrait mieux s'organiser
et mettre en place un service d'ordre
dans les endroits chauds on passe à un
autre dossier chaud lui aussi c'est
l'arrestation de carlos ghosn le
président de renault nissan
il est depuis deux jours en garde à vue
cette garde à vue qui peut durer jusqu'à
trois semaines
il est soupçonné de fraude fiscale et ce
qui surprend entre autres dans ce
dossier c'est la virulence de la
réaction des japonais par rapport à
carlos ghosn écoutez ce qu'a dit hiroto
saikawa c'est le président exécutif de
nissan c'est à dire le numéro deux de
l'entreprise
il a été placé là par carlos ghosn avec
qui il a fait toute sa carrière
et voilà ce qu'il disait juste au moment
où on apprenait l'arrestation de carlos
ghosn ne sont pas tous ces reproches là
on les avait jamais entendu jusque là on
a l'impression que c'est d'un seul coup
le couvercle qui saute alors même que
carlos ghosn a quand même contribué à
sauver ni salle qui était en grande aux
réer nourrir la thèse du complot qu'on
ne dirait pas d'autre mot parce que ce
qu'il reproche à renault c'est d'avoir
43%
de nissan c'est quelque chose qui n'a
rien à voir avec la sphère de se pose
lee froz fraude fiscale donc il y à là
quelque chose de pas net dans le système
japonais qui est extrêmement
problématique et nous savons très bien
qui va nourrir la thèse du complot j'ai
pas de preuve le gouvernement
apparemment manque aussi manque beaucoup
aussi d'informations sur le cas de
carlos cause mais honnêtement et
l'énorme problème dans le capitalisme
japonais et c'est une crispation qu'on
constate dans beaucoup d'autres pays une
crispation face à la mondialisation et à
la façon dont un bijou nationale comme
nissan qui est quand même colossal
représente un enjeu politique économique
impérial même considérable et je crois
que la sphère carlos ghost dépasse
largement le cas de l'individu gosse
mais pose le problème de du libre
échange et et de l'économie ouverte
telle qu'elle est elle nous a été
présenté comme désirable depuis des
décennies alors même que même si ça
n'excuse en rien de fraude et fils
carlos ghosn est reconnu comme étant un
très grand patron du secteur l'homme qui
a probablement sauvé ni sable comme le
rappelait ce matin thierry breton ancien
ministre de l'économie qui connaît très
bien le japon et qui était chez nos
confrères de france inter ce que carlos
ghosn a fait je pense sincèrement après
avoir été celui que louches et zaire a
choisi lui seul pouvait le faire il a
réalisé une je dirais vraiment un
exploit managériale c'est pour ça que
tout ceci m'attriste profondément si
jamais c'est avéré c'est ça a été un
immense chef d'entreprise café de
renault le premier acteur mondial ne
l'oublions pas je sais je mais ils sont
un gramme et japonais ou alors ils ont
organisé une espèce de pièges comme le
comme le laisse entendre
christian makarian mais christian
makarian a tout à fait raison de dire
que c'est une réaction de nationalisme
brutale ça me semble totalement avéré
après la question et on voit que la
question la brutalité
nationale dans les relations économiques
est aujourd'hui en pleine croissance
vous dire il ya trump hier doan enfin on
est dans une situation aujourd'hui la
brutalité fait partie des règles du jeu
et on voit bien le mélange maintenant le
politique s'immisce dans l'économie ça
c'est une nouvelle forme de
mondialisation
après se voir la justice en l'occurrence
puisque c'est le bureau du procureur de
taux que l'on est et on sait bien que
effectivement les japonais ont de tout
temps mais un lien extrêmement fort
entre nationalisme et économie c'est
c'est leur culture c'est comme ça qu'ils
ont construit la puissance japonaise
alors après il ya un sujet moi je trouve
qui est aussi celui de carlos ghosn
comment n'at-il pas senti venir les
choses moi c'est une question que je me
pose pas ce que c'est quand même pas un
perdreau de l'année
et ça fait des années même j'allais dire
des dizaines d'années peut-être pas
autant que ça mais en tout cas ça fait
très longtemps qu'on savait que sa
relation à l'argent était une relation
il ne s'en cachait pas puisqu'il y avait
aussi un problème pour voter son salaire
avec l'actionnaire état pour renault que
de très longue date on sait que c'est
quelqu'un qui aime l'argent et qui
demande d'avoir un salaire beaucoup plus
élevés que ceux qui ont des postes
équivalents par rapport aux 6,1 alors
comment n'at-il pas senti venir le
danger c'est une question que je me pose
parce que ça m'étonnerait puisque les
choses viennent aussi de l'entreprise on
voit bien il ya eu quelque chose de
l'ordre du complot à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise
comment se fait-il qu'il a été surpris
je m'interroge là dessus et et je me
demande
enfin je me demande quand les choses on
peut rester à ce point secrète philibert
c'est arrogant cette histoire écoutez
moi c'est encore plus fort qu'avant
puisque ça à la part entre le vrai
de deux choses l'une ou bien carlos
ghosn est une source que nous sommes
tenus de croire jusqu'à ce qu'on ait
prouvé le contraire ça n'a pas l'air
d'embarrasser beaucoup monsieur hiroto
saikawa déjà décidé que c'était fait la
deuxième hypothèse il n'est pas il n'est
pas innocent et là je voudrais vous
raconter une histoire
j'étais lié avec le cardinal lustiger
qu'1 et et m'a demandé de lui servir de
sparring partner pour un livre qui
voulait écrire c'était dans l'aveyron
chez moi et on se faisait servir nos
repas par un excellent restaurant voisin
et un jour jeudi au cardinal vous savez
ils font un très bon babaorum léger
excellent
on pourra pas travailler après faites ce
que vous voulez moi j'en prends je le
prends je lui fais goûter et idy a en
effet tu as raison tu peut en commander
un pour demain et là je commence à
rigoler pourquoi rigole tube parce que
amener un prince de l'église à commettre
un péché c'est satisfaisant pour tu n'y
connais rien at il dit le péché ce n'est
pas la gourmandise la gourmandise c'est
au contraire profiter des beautés que
dont nous pouvons jouir et qui sont tout
à la gloire de dieu ce qu'il pêchait et
qui a été très mal traduit par cette
stupide église du 19e siècle qu'il
détestait absolument c'est la
gloutonnerie
et si c'est le cas c'est en effet à un
cas de gloutonnerie avancé auxquels on a
affaire
mais cette bretonne rila ça n'est pas
celle éventuellement et nous ne le
savons pas encore de monsieur ghosn
c'est celle de l'ensemble des dirigeants
dans ce pays et ça les gilets jaunes
on n'a pas besoin qu'on leur montre du
doigt pour qu'ils comprennent que c'est
ce qui est là le ce qui fait que le
poisson pourrit par la tête
vous êtes assez partagés sur dans vos
réactions sur internet on vous pose la
question sur twitter trouvez-vous la
détention de carlos ghosn justifier
alors là c'est 69 % oui donc à une vraie
une vraie majorité mais il ya quand même
des doutes yann nicol qui nous dit je ne
suis pas particulièrement fan de carlos
ghosn mais ça ressemble à un coup d'état
interne alors que monsieur babineau dit
si c'est avéré il n'a pas seulement
trompé le japon mais aussi le fisc
français alors pour l'instant il faut le
dire il ya rien là dessus bono le maire
l'a répété hier franck nous dit je
trouve que cette affaire ne lui
correspond pas je pense qu'il a été
piégé et une réaction enfin 10 aux
métriques qui nous dit les intérêts
nationaux commencent à primer sur la
mondialisation sauvage c'est une bonne
chose
chacun j'ai dû voir je vais disputer
quarante jours de garde à vue ce qui
n'arrivait japon moi j'avoue avoir brisé
le vase de soissons center mais moi je
voudrais jouer un petit peu là le
trouble fête même si je suis entièrement
d'accord avec tout ce qui a été dit je
voudrais simplement rappeler cette chose
il n'ya jamais eu deux hommes d'affaires
qui ont eu des problèmes fiscaux en
france il ya jamais eu des problèmes
d'actionnariat dans l'autre sens quand
une entreprise étrangère posséder une
entreprise française
imaginons simplement que la même chose
se soit produite avec un homme
d'affaires japonais d'une entreprise qui
dominerait une entreprise française ou
garantie que toutes les réactions autour
de cette table
ce serait exactement à l'opposé tout le
monde à claude irait en disant c'est
formidable c'est un scandale les jeunes
du nationalisme qui chez nous et on le
voit très bien dans cette affaire c'est
à dire qu'on défend quand même notre
champion renault face aux méchants
japonais et il ya aussi du national
pensez aussi à l'affairé air france klm
c'est aussi le même si les mêmes
situations où la france est dominante
sur le plan capitalistique et donc moi
je me réjouis de voir à quel point nous
sommes nous nous sommes pour
l'intégrisme capitalistes français dans
cette affaire c'est tout à fait
impressionnant alors tout le monde n'est
pas un sou livres journaux je le
dépassais traction de nicolas dupont
aignan qui est sur le même sur le même
registre comme ce syndicat oies en aucun
cas les terres actionnaires auraient dû
laisser se développer ainsi la
présidence d'un seul individu sur un
groupe industriel oc significatif pour
la faune peut tout dire j'ai même
entendu que ça arrange et le
gouvernement et que macro était derrière
parce que ça faisait effet de dispersion
par rapport au gilet jaune donc et
qu'enfin un patron punis au moment où
les jets les jeunes se soulève sa
remettait la balance la flèche de la
balance au milieu c'est n'importe quoi
ce qui moi je trouvais assez frappant
c'est l'opacité qui se poursuit nous ne
savons pas précisément tout cas le
ministre bruno le maire a l'air de dire
qu'il manque d'informations et nous ne
savons pas précisément ce qui lui est
reprochée ne savons pas du tout quelles
sont ses conditions de détention en
dehors des trois bols de riz par jour de
l'eau oui de l'eau pour seule boisson
est encore aisé à régime spartiate et et
du tatami sur lequel il va coucher
effectivement comme philippe l'a dit
peut-être si on va jusqu'au bout des
lèvres à vue pendant trois semaines faut
ajouter que la loi japonaise a été
changé cette année au mois de juin et
que la durée de garde à vue a été
prolongée c'est donc une mesure toute
fraîche qui avait fait d'ailleurs débat
à l'époque où au japon et nous ne savons
toujours pas
s'il ya eu complot ou pas donc ce qui
est frappant c'est que ce capitalisme
qui nous cache les richesses des grands
patrons nous cache aussi leur
culpabilité leurs fautes et la façon
dont ils peuvent tomber donc cette
affaire échappe complètement
à l'heure de la mondialisation de la
transparence de l'information à la
nanoseconde à tout le monde et moi je
trouve ça véritablement angoissant je
suis moi je trouve qu'il ya quelque
chose d'assez intéressant ça m'angoisse
pas du tout dans la manière dont on est
un homme extrêmement puissant sous les
feux des projecteurs et dont on n'est
plus rien du jour au lendemain je trouve
c'est un truc moi ça me rappelle
dominique strauss kahn je pensais à ça
aussi ça me rappelle la façon dont tous
styles brice l'enm école à la façon dont
poutine par exemple des zincs ses
opposants ou r2 on est dans un monde où
surtout on s'aperçoit que la protection
entre puissants quelque part elle ne
fonctionne plus et il peut y avoir des
retournements d'alliances qui sont
absolument pas prévu et ça on peut dire
que c'est c'est dommage on peut dire
aussi que ça montre on est dans un
moment de transition en fait on ne sait
plus très bien qui a d'ailleurs quelle
est la règle qui s'applique y compris
sur la protection entre ceux qui
devraient se protéger et la question de
l'argent est évidemment un truc
fondamental c'est à dire que sous
couvert de morale de toute façon chacun
sera d'accord sur le fait que le salaire
de carlos ghosn était largement
disproportionnée en plus que il
affichait un sentiment d'impunité totale
puisque au fond il fraudait publiquement
enfin au fond ils fraudent et
publiquement parce qu'il était persuadé
qu'il ne serais je l'avais un sentiment
d'impunité dont il ya quelque chose là
qui fonctionne sur le but mais je ne
savais pas qu il fraudait le fisc ce qui
a été dit assez clairement c'est que
tous ces salaires et tous et toutes
étaient publiques en fait au japon et
donc c'est pour ça que la question du
complot et pourquoi ça s'est déclenché à
ce moment là a été a été arrosée voilà
on va revenir en france si vous le
voulez bien pour parler des syndicats
qui traverse une passe un peu compliqué
par exemple la force ouvrière où tous
les grands chefs à plumes sont réunis
pendant deux jours pour essayer de
trouver un nouveau patron
un nouveau scrutin général après pascal
pavageau qui s'était rendu célèbre pour
avoir mis en fiches l'ensemble des
dirigeants du syndicat et puis
évidemment il ya le fait que
les syndicats sont un peu largué dans ce
mouvement des gilets jaunes écouter des
témoignages de dirigeants syndicaux
comme celui de patrice clos alors c'est
le secrétaire général de force ouvrière
transports il était ce matin sur bfm tv
et alors lui les gilet jaune bas s'il
peut leur donner quelques conseils il
est bien content soutiennent une
expertise puisqu'on a vu des choses
quand même là les barrages c'est
intéressant ça une expertise
un service d'ordre vous voulez dire
service d'ordre et comment de faire un
barrage on avait on voit des choses de
même encore aujourd'hui c'est en matière
de sécurité c'est servira par exemple
mais on ne savait jamais devant des
véhicules tout simplement on a toujours
quelque chose qui entre le véhicule et
une ou deux personnes mais jamais un
être humain devant le véhicule
il faut compléter ce tableau je propose
de réécouter ce que tu es philippe
martinez le patron de la cgt
c'était la semaine dernière est lui
aussi reconnaissez pas qu'il avait quand
même des choses à apprendre de ce
mouvement d gilet jaune
intellectuellement et pratiquement on en
tire des enseignements oui il faut
élargir la pratique et plus internet des
moyens de communication plus moderne que
les distributions de tracts et ça on
sent une pratique mais ce qu'on veut
c'est aussi que le message il soit bien
entendu une mobilisation par internet
c'est important ça permet de mais ça ne
suffit pas
ils sont un peu aux fraises là nos amis
syndicats le gang des moustaches
écoutez c'est touchant d'entendre le
secrétaire général de la cgt dont
d'ailleurs on peut rappeler aussi
qu'elle a connu quelques problèmes de
leadership avec l'élimination du
prédécesseur de monsieur martinez pour
des raisons de 30 vies qui était
considéré à juste ou injuste titre comme
étant tout à fait excessif mais enfin
c'est quand même très touchant de voir
on est en 2018 si je bien fait mes
calculs
le secrétaire général de la cgt
découvrir qu'internet est un puissant
moyen de mobilisation et on peut même
lui dire que les réseaux sociaux aussi
l'équipement oui on a plus besoin du
coût de ces syndicats cuistot ma
carrière on voit qu'ils sont quand même
un peu en dehors des dés
les luttes sociales et de la même façon
dans les dossiers récents comme la
réforme du code du travail
ils ont manifesté mais personne ne les
écoute et pour reprendre votre
formulation nous n'avons plus besoin de
ces syndicats avez-vous dit de ces
syndicale là mais des syndicats oui ce
sont
les intermédiaires naturel les pouvoirs
publics par rapport à toute la sphère
sociale en scandinavie ou en allemagne
ça se passe beaucoup mieux l'apathie les
jaunes il n'y a pas de gilet jaune
il doit y avoir des mouvements s'il ya
déjà les jeunes en belgique un petit
mouvement qui s'est développée mais la
façon dont le syndicalisme est construit
en france
fondamentalement sur la notion de lutte
des classes qui a été compensé par une
cogestion général c'est ça qui est en
cause et qui est complètement débordé
aujourd'hui du reste c'est pas la
première fois dans les grands conflits
sociaux plusieurs fois les syndicats ont
été débordés là ils essaient de
récupérer que ce soient fous ou la cgt
j'y réponds pas mais la question qui se
pose est hélas revient à l'état à l'état
central comment l'état peut-il
fonctionner par rapport aux différents
échelons sociaux sans les syndicats
c'est très difficile il ne faut pas être
anti syndicale mais ce sont ces
syndicale a donc comme philippe l'a
rappelé les agissements paraissent très
très éloignées parfois parfois je ne
veux pas généraliser de la morale
publique généralement admise
eh bien ce sont ces syndicats là qui
apparaissent aujourd'hui totalement
ringardisé totalement hors de la tension
sociale et du fameux conflit entre le
centre et la périphérie
on peut quand même s'étonner que le
gouvernement mais pas répondu à la
proposition de laurent berger
d'organiser très rapidement une table
ronde de l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés parce que peut-être sur cette
affaire de gilet jaune l'orangé proposé
de réunir toutes les parties prenantes
sauf justement les îles et lola
l'enquêté galop d'essai face aux
pilleurs et de choses rires parce que je
crois que la fédération fo des
transports un point d'information est
allé plus loin elle et elle est en train
de rejoindre le mouvement
ce qui est très inquiétant d'ailleurs
pour le gouvenement c'est très
inquiétant parce qu'elle fait la tuerait
transports il faut c'est quand même pas
mal de division et surtout c'est pas mal
de camions mais non je vais moi dans le
sens de fitch bay à moi j'ai pas du tout
compris
c'était merveilleux ce qu'a proposé
laurent berger parce qu'il proposait de
toute façon très cdt très deuxième
gauche
une conférence qui était pas du tout une
conférence uniquement avec les syndicats
qui étaient c'est au gouvernement de
fixer la géométrie de l'ordre du jour
les accouveurs c'était tout à fait sûr
là où vers sa fin en tout cas et le
gouvernement
tout de suite y est ce qui est quand
même alors que c'était magnifique porte
de sortie à mon avis par le haut pour
tout le monde ne pas faire perdre là-bas
la face reconnaître ces gilet jaune
remettent les syndicats dans le cou
reposer des questions de fond un lucine
dont nous parlions sur l'écologie sur la
transition écologique
j'avoue j'avoue n'avoir pas compris
sinon que là il ya eu un réflexe un peu
d'autorité et non pas une position
d'autorité véritablement et il peut-être
quelque chose d'un peu de techno comme
on dit quelques chiffres pour nourrir le
débat sur twitter on vous pose la
question évidemment ce pas un sondage
puisque ce sont les internautes qui
suivent l'émission qui réagissent selon
vous faut-il sauver syndicalisme
français question volontairement un peu
provocatrice 68 % répondent non et puis
cette fois ci c'est un sondage est donc
là c'est ça une valeur de 2,2
représentative
le sondage viavoice pour le figaro de
lundi dernier à titre personnel pensez
vous que les syndiqués en france de
manière générale sont des freins à la
réforme ou sont utiles pour engager les
transformations et bien il ya une
majorité à la fois dans le grand public
et chez les salariés qui considère que
les salades les syndicats sont devenus
des freins est ce aussi votre avis nous
illumine peut-être je reprendrai ce qu'a
dit christian makarian ces syndicats là
et encore c'est difficile en fait
d'associer tous les syndicats par
exemple c'est vrai que la cfdt à cette
tradition en tout cas de mettre des
propositions de contenu sur la table
après sur le rapport de force parce
qu'on est quand même pas dans un monde
de bisounours sur la question de salaire
que sur la question du pouvoir d'achat
qui était quand même posé par les gilet
jaune
je suis pas sûr que la cfdt soit le
meilleur syndicats le syndicat le plus
représentatif sur la défense du pouvoir
d'achat
moi je voulais dire juste une petite
chose c'est que ça montre qu'on manque
complètement de contre-pouvoir cette
affaire déjà les jaunes c'est à dire que
les maires n'ont pas joué leur rôle de
manière correcte je pense qu'ils
auraient dû être plus actifs
les syndicats ne l'ont pas jouer il au
monde et sur la question la proposition
de laurent berger elle est certes très
bonne sur le principe et quand on
philosophe et quand on est à sion
secours mais sauf que les gilets jaunes
n'ont pas de représentants comme ça a
été rappelé ils sont extraits de remise
ils ont ils enfin parce que enfin moi je
suis peut-être la seule autour de la
terre à votre regardez la vidéo de
jacqueline qui a été présentée partout
sur bfm télé compagnie jacqueline son
cul donc comme la leader des gilets
jaunes qui est quand même une folle
incroyable qui a quand même justifier le
fait qu'ils aient eu un mort en iran
c'est la faute du gouvernement
donc moi je pense qu'il ya une forme
d'extrémisme en tout cas dans les
personnes qui ont été mises en avant qui
ne correspond pas non mais attendez les
parents temps de me jauger et je veux
changer le nom je pense aussi qu'il ya
une extrême diversité en fait des
positions j'ai eu aussi du gilet jaune
dire on est des grands écologistes on ne
fait pas ça par anti écologiste ont fait
ça parce qu'on est prisonnier de la
voiture donc il ya des choses qui font
que
comment dirais je crée la dynamique de
représentation du gilet jaune je suis
pas sûr que ce soit si simple que riera
que tactiquement c'était au moins
tactiquement c'était une bonne idée pour
arriver à sortir assez wilshere qui sauf
qu'il faut rétablir l'ordre public je
suis enfin la préfète automne atta mills
et moi mais rétablir leur bec et après
on fera une conférence économique et
jean-claude épineuse pas terrible pour
la pour la planète
alors pendant que philippe meyer
récupère son son micro je suis passé
qu'on vous entende encore parce que
voilà comme je vois qu'une pile est
tombé donc on va on va s'occuper de ça
tout de suite et je suis sûr que
christian mcaleer d'étude intéressant à
nous dire
en attendant réputée physique et chergui
merci de
demandez de meublés pas du tout enfin
après l'incident technique
non je crois je crois que il y a
après le maquereau nice mlle dégagisme
la restructuration de la vie politique
telle qu'elle s'est accomplie en 2017
il ya une phase maintenant qui concerne
les syndicats mais qu'il ne faut pas
tomber dans un radicalisme antisyndicale
pas plus qu'il faut être dans une
syndicales au fils y voilà absolument
ou la trinitrine syndicalo la tri il
faut il faut observer les choses de
façon très pragmatique nous avons besoin
de syndicats les la question des
retraites par exemple tous ces accords
de branche la france un record de
branches dans l'eure en europe
ça passe par des intermédiaires part je
pense qu'il faut simplifier tout ça
voilà comment simplifier tout cela et
les syndicats sont attachés au monde
ancien et c'est ce que démontre à mon
avis cette affaire de gilet jaune c'est
que les syndicats d'un coût représente
l'ancien système
c'est un petit peu ce que de l'arcsi
atteint chantant juste nicole jeudi dans
l'argent je nicolodi je ne suis pas pour
que dans l'isère qui font de l'argent
tel qu'il existe depuis des années il
faut qu'ils se réforment clos qui nous
dit aussi le syndicalisme doit s'adapter
aux changements de société être plus
clair dans sa gestion financière trop
d'abus et goudron ajoutent-ils les
syndicats doivent se renouveler
profondément philippe may à vous être
devenu audible quand je vais l'écoutant
non je voulais rebondir sur la
suggestion de lucile selon laquelle le
problème c'est l'ordre public mais là
aussi est ce que le gouvernement n'avait
pas la possibilité de prendre une
initiative
après ce qui s'est passé le week-end
dernier c'est à dire de dire puisque les
jets les jo dans l'intention de
continuer leur dire bon d'accord vous
continuez nous respectons le droit de
manifestation mais vous ne pouvez pas
continuer dans des conditions de
sécurité qui sont celles là allez dans
les préfectures et dans les
sous-préfectures déclaré vous regardons
ensemble comme on peut assurer la
sécurité
nous nous opposons aux blocages comme
nous l'avons toujours dit donc
négociera ça avec vous enfin on réglera
ça avec vous mais là aussi il me semble
que l'absence d'initiatives du
gouvernement dans ce dans ce domaine là
qu'est ce qui va se passer si samedi
prochain puisqu'il ya cette montée sur
paris est en train de se préparer qu'est
ce qui va se passer s'il ya de nouveau
des incidents graves des blessés graves
et peut-être aussi des morts c'est en
tout cas une nouvelle funeste pour le
gouvernement et pour tous les citoyens
que de voir les syndicats complètement
largués et de l'autre côté un mouvement
complètement incontrôlable je veux dire
il ya plus de levier en a l'impression
que le gouvernement n'a plus de manette
sur lesquels tirés entre il ya plus de
contre-pouvoirs et il n'y a plus de roy
j cr de mécanismes vous donnez à l'ordre
en eau du système et ils ne se transmet
pas la chaîne et brisé un mai 68 non
plus il n'y avait pas vraiment de
représentants du côté des étudiants il y
avait un peu du 9 et 7 u 9 n'avait
aucune autorité sur rien elle était
comme celles comme l'unef d'aujourd'hui
elle représentait un très petit nombre
d'étudiants mais le les pouvoirs publics
et notamment en son temps le regretté
préfet grimont ont su faire ce qu'il
fallait faire pour trouver des gens avec
qui discuter et pour tenir les forces de
l'ordre qui étaient autrement plus
brutale qu'elle ne le sont aujourd'hui
pour les tenir dans la dans la limite du
longe observe juste qu'il y avait parmi
les représentants par exemple à lille
l'une des trois organisatrices de la
manifestation a dit je suis une
écologiste
après on a vu des autres qui conduisait
les quatre cas non mais il ya quelque
chose
même dans la relation à la voiture dans
la revendication autour du pouvoir
d'achat il y avait des indications
diamétralement opposées c'est donc un
mouvement assez hauts patrimoines soyons
très satisfaisant équitable comme dit
philippe meyer en 68 il ya eu un
mouvement vers le mouvement ouvrier
lui-même était tout à fait incontrôlés
et on a identifié des leaders étudiants
qui d'ailleurs ça leur a réussi ton avis
y avait-il cher christophe autant de
divergences sur les contenus gens n'en
suis pas sûr oui mais alors cela dit si
ce droit là si ce droit à la truffe mans
est réservé au bac + 12
il faut le dire carrément mais lucide
mon caractère hétéroclite élitisme que
laissait entendre christophe lebon la
question le caractère hétéroclite voire
complètement contradictoires de ses
revendications et est en train de
définir l'identité même de ce type de
mouvement c'est à dire qu'on ne sait pas
par où les attraper et c'est ça qui est
devenu dangereux et en soit c'est un
fait social sociologique politique tout
à fait majeure dont moi je refuse de
régler sade par la simplification en
disant ils sont hors la loi il faut que
l'ordre public soit rétabli c'est plus
que ce que j'ai dit non j'ai dit je n'ai
pas dit que vous l'aviez dit jeudi
qu'elle revient pas sur les jours je
viens après à la je pense quand même
qu'il faut méditer ce qui est en train
de se passer et que les histoires de
fractures de rupture de périphérie et de
centres sont des thèses mais que tout de
même elle tourne
elles ont un sens un parfum de vérité
parfois de vérité les gens qui
manifestent avec parfois beaucoup de vue
a été voir de violences exprime aussi
une désespérance et la façon dont on
tient à la bagnole c'est le dernier
biens matériels que certains peuvent y
dont je t'en fiches et surtout il faut
donc a donc déjà beaucoup parlé des
gilets jaunes et des motivations du
mouvement et puis apparemment il n'est
pas terminée donc on aura peut-être
l'occasion de revenir sur ce sujet il
nous reste quelques minutes pour parler
des républicains qui se cherche toujours
une tête de liste pour les élections
européennes qui je vous le rappelle
auront lieu en mai prochain laurent
wauquiez n'a pas pris sa décision
alors est-ce que bien bon profil pour
pour
prendre la tête de cette liste ya un nom
qui circule depuis le week-end dernier
c'est celui d'un professeur de
philosophie qui s'appelle françois
xavier bellamy vous le connaissez
peut-être si vous êtes lecteur du figaro
magazine car nous lui avons consacré une
couverture il y a quelques semaines il a
33 ans il est maire adjoint divers
droite de versailles on parle de lui il
ne dit pas non il a un profil on va dire
conservateur peut être un petit peu trop
pour gérard larcher le président du
sénat
écoutez il commentait ce matin gérard
larcher la possibilité d'une candidature
bellamy me correspond pas j'avais redon
oc chez votre droite
est ce que c'est votre droit mais le
sujet sais pas françois-xavier bellamy c
est ce que le projet que nous allons
porter aux européennes est un projet qui
va rassembler l'ensemble de la famille
st république a autour des valeurs du
ppe sur des sujets aussi importants que
l'identité la crise migratoire autour
des valeurs humanistes
voilà c'est important les valeurs
humanistes on rappellera pour ce que
vous avez bel ami ne fait pas mystère de
ses convictions catholiques est ce qu'il
ya un bon candidat
un portrait-robot christophe de voc
donner une tête de liste à quelqu'un qui
n'est pas connu du tout
malgré leur malgré figaro magazine dont
il est un petit peu plus désormais c'est
vrai est ce que ça vous paraît à un coup
trop risqué ou une bonne gestion
d'impression c'est une un peu une patate
chaude que ces leaders de républicains
essaient de se refiler écoute après toi
si tu veux bien aller les européennes je
sois vraiment très bien pour les
européennes
et on dirait qu'ils ont les pronostics
ne sont pas bons parce que le
positionnement n'est pas clair toujours
la même chose
une loi de la vraie rhétorique ça et
donc ils ont ils se disent bon bah comme
on d'ailleurs on peut pas se mettre
d'accord entre nous entre nous les
grands barons parce que s'il y en a un
qui prend un avantage sur l'autre etc
puis on n'est pas d'accord sur l'europe
vous savez très bien qu'au sein de la
droite il ya au moins deux visions de
l'europe une vision disons libera le
traditionnel raffarin et une vision
beaucoup plus conservatrice nationaliste
wauquiez dokpesi souverainiste donc à
l'asie françois-xavier vous dire est ce
que c'est ça à lyon vas-y jeune homme et
il a tous les talents pour ce faire je
crois qu'il n'a pas la notoriété
suffisante et surtout il peut pas
remplacer la décision du programme de
l'agenda politique de cette fameuse
liste républicaine sur twitter vous pose
la question qui verriez-vous en tête de
liste européenne du côté des
républicains alors ça c'est ouvert
laurence tout dit françois xavier b la
vie mais frangine nous dit pourquoi pas
à bruno retailleau le patron du groupe
l'est républicain au sénat tandis que
nelly part de jean leonetti qu'est le
numéro deux du parti qui effectivement a
été évoqué comme tête de liste alors que
valérie nous dit nicolas sarkozy
il en met juste en rêve parce que je ne
crois pas qu'il se remettra en politique
et vous le sisp il est ce que vous avez
un candidat ou une candidate pour les
républicains pour votre liste demande
juste une chose c'est qu'ils aient
encore aux républicains parce que
j'avais regardé
j'avais vu xavier bertrand par exemple
était assez plébiscitée dans les
sondages début octobre sur le fait de
pouvoir être tête de liste d'une liste
de droite
je crois que bon ça peut plus être le
cas pour les républicains donc la
question au fond c est ce que les
républicains réussiront un ferme liste
de droite
étant donné la façon dont ils ont des
bisbilles entre eux c'est pas seulement
se refiler la patate chaude
c est ce qui représente encore la droite
donc sa sage je tenais à le dire
ensuite sur françois xavier bellamy je
me disais mais au fond c'est un peu un
profil à la emmanuel macron de droite
c'est à dire c'est un intello il a des
très beaux duels aux îles et il a des
supers du bleu il est à versailles file
est hyper bien identifiés et où il a un
côté gendre idéal mais on a déjà un
grand intello à la tête de l'état et on
s'aperçoit que ça fonctionne pas si bien
que ça et je me demande s'il faut
refaire le coup de l'intello qui en même
temps est élu et puis qui va vous
expliquer comment est ce que ça
fonctionne alors qu'ils allaient chez
les jaunes donc moi je pense les
intellectuels que vous retirez pourtant
mais bien sûr mais que nous requérons
tous à la demande de guillaume mais
l'outsider je suis pour geneviève de
fontenay
mais la force xavier bellamy est
incontestablement une tête bien faite
très bien fait mais ce qu'une tête bien
faite c'est une tête de liste jean suis
pas sûr d'autant plus que si il est
désigné comme tête de liste ça sera
parce que les autres n'arrivent pas à se
mettre d'accord c'est à dire que dans le
panier de crabes on se donne tout le
monde donne des coups à tout le monde
finalement on dit en revanche est la
chose la plus certaine c'est que si les
têtes de liste ee 6 et il sera élu
nécessairement comme toutes les têtes de
liste le seront à peine sera-t-il élu
que tous les crabes se retourneront
contre lui pour essayer de lui retirer
le pouvoir et laura qui leur a acquise
en étant devenu tête de liste donc je ne
suis pas très sûr que tout ça sorte la
droite du marasme dans lequel elle
croupit gestion maccagnan c'est une
bonne idée ou c'est trop risqué
je ne sais pas shaggy homme je n'ai
jamais rencontré la une du figaro
magazine personnage qui fait la une mais
je veux bien après avoir lu l'excellent
numéro du figaro magazine je veux bien
concédé que c'est un personnage nouveau
est tout à fait intéressant mais si
j'étais lui je n'irai pas parce que on
ne peut pas aller aux élections
européennes à la tête
au nom d'une formation qui n'a aucune
idée de ce qu'elle veut faire de
l'europe dans le futur immédiat dans un
futur proche
donc ou bien monsieur bel ami va servir
de caution propre sur lui et se fera
rouler dans la farine
aussitôt après et ou bien alors il exige
des éclaircissements et que la droite
trouve dans les mois qui viennent un
point de vue sur l'europe ce qui
m'étonnerait énormément et à ce moment
là le choisira quelqu'un doté à ce
moment-là bellamy n'aura aucune chance
parce que le méchant qui aura imposé son
point de vue dira je veux moi la place
et c'est pas bellamy qu'il aura donc je
pense que c'est bien ça qui est dommage
le profil de monsieur bellamy est très
intéressante et riche est nouveau et moi
contrairement à voulu s'il ne me gêne
pas que ce soit l'intérêt de plus parce
que vous venez de dire ce qu'on montre
ancien des gilet jaune et maintenant
vous dessoudé les intellos donc il va
falloir qu'elle avait des corps saints
mystères 60
je plaisantais loup il va falloir quand
même des gens pour assumer les fonctions
non plus avec le président de la
république certains intellectuels n'est
pas que cela il est aussi un homme qui
sait se servir de son intelligence est
un homme qui a des instructions et qu'il
a montré dans les concours qu'il a
réussis même dans celui qui l'a raté
mais je ne dirais pas que c'est non
c'est pas méchant c'est juste que c'est
juste pour rappeler qu'un varia rigueur
chez lui quand même c'est pas rien aux
normes est un intellectuel c'est pas
tout à fait ça c'est à dire c'est
quelqu'un qui m'aime quelqu'un de
cultivé ou quelqu'un d'instruit et
devient pas pour autant
c'est quelqu'un qui en est fait
ni à tous les toutes les
caractéristiques de l'homme trop bien
pour se livrer à cette manoeuvre là pour
qu'on la place de michel barnier plein
d'idées sur cher internaute outre bel
ami vous ne parliez de jeunes comme
aurélien pradié lydia guirous ce ou
fabien di filippo et bien là on vaut
qaîda que l'embarras du choix puisque en
fin de compte c'est lui qui va décider
qui sera cette tête de liste merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre d'avoir
accepté notre invitation point de vue
c'est fini pour ce soir mais nous
revenons de main bien sûr à la même
heure et au même endroit
[Musique]